yet again
congratulations i feel like this is a
double congratulations though because
this movie should have come out sooner
uh yes thank you thank you i'm glad it's
getting the netflix audience now though
so let's start with the audition process
here i was reading
that anthony knew that you were his
steve after you read just one single
scene for him so do you remember what
that scene was
and what'd that moment feel like to you
did it kind of feel like
something clicked on that next level you
know
this this role is for me kind of feel um
yes i think you know it's so funny
because the process was so
it was so long i remember i got the
script a year before
even i ended up actually meeting anthony
i think there was a different director
and i didn't get the part and then i
came back and i and they they were like
oh do you still want to do it and i was
like i don't think i can i started i got
discouraged i was like okay well i'm not
i'm not good enough to do this thing
and so um av kaufman our casting
director convinced me to go in
to meet anthony and do the camera test
with anthony and all the producers
and they had me read the opening
monologue which was
which is now a voice over in the film
where steve talks about
what it's like um what it's like uh how
people see him
and what it's like to be in prison right
now and and
in dealing with this idea of being a
monster playing with the mi monster am i
not
that's what the prosecutor called me um
and that was that was the monologue and
i think that's all i did
and so i guess that's what he's talking
about so i think that's pretty cool you
know
it's so wild to me to think about
anybody else directing this movie
because it's got
it's got such a specific style that i
think i can
sense his music video sensibilities in
it in a way so i can't imagine
anybody else directing this yeah yeah i
know
i agree what was what was it like
working with him with
with that in mind given his extensive
uh filmography in the music video sector
can you
detect kind of a unique approach to
directing when working with someone with
his kind of experience yes well i think
what anthony does so well first of his
visuals are
it's beautiful and and i think um
there's some really just pretty pretty
pictures in that in that film and i
think it was it lended so much towards
who steve was and how steve saw it
because ultimately the movie is through
steve's eyes and
steve's movie that he made so no one
better than to kind of get you know
anthony was a photographer before he was
a music video director so i think he
really understood
that element to it but also his
directing styles thematically
some of the the choices we made um
lend it towards a much larger picture
because i do think that's the thing
about the movie the movie is so much
bigger
than just steve's individual experience
and
um anthony did a really good job at min
meshing the two together
um without me even having to do any work
you know all i had to do was just be
honest to be truthful to steve and
anthony kind of just told a story you
know and
so yeah i think i think he's he's great
for that
he really is it's also a little strange
for me to think about when you made this
movie given how much you've made
since so i i think it was something like
what was it
mud bound um it comes at night and then
this so was there anything about working
with those two ensembles
right before jumping into this movie
that i don't know kind of
influenced you at all especially given
the fact that like you are the star you
are the headliner of this one
yes it was very different i think you
know what was nice
was seeing i was understanding how a set
worked
just the bare bones of just like okay to
be number one on the call sheet how are
they moving
and you know seeing joel um specifically
in carmen
and and how they prepped how they asked
how they talk to the director
how they how they navigated when things
didn't
work and figuring out how do we you know
collaborate in a moment how do we
utilize the time we have
um because i you know i got to the set
and i was suddenly in every scene of a
movie and i remember it was such a short
shoot and
it would be like you know usually on a
big movie you have like you can shoot
three scenes for the day
we will shoot seven so be like you gotta
get it done a couple takes in and move
on to the next thing
it was like tv to an extent so i think
um though that skill set and watching
how they kept the morale up
um even watching jennifer ely on this
movie though she was very kind she knew
everyone's name
even the extras she would say good
morning she was always on time and it
was just these types of like
the work ethic that kind of played into
it um lends to
being able to do the work better and be
able to be the artist you want to be and
tell the story you want to tell
you know i love that quality you
highlight and jennifer ely i feel like
that is
that's so important on every single set
out there i did want to ask you about
the vo
experience on this one because there's a
significant amount of it and
it's incredibly important to the film
overall the feel of it and the style of
it so
when you have to do something like that
is it as simple as
tapping back into what you did to be
steve on set
and bringing it into the recording booth
or there are or are there new techniques
involved
in order for the vo to serve with the
film overall needs
yeah that's a great question i think
that was something i had to figure out
in real time too because i had never
done that before
and um it was it was looking at the
movie and then
anthony allowed me to see it and then
kind of digest that part because the
good thing about the voiceover it is
steve after it's all happened steve
after he's gone through the experience
then telling the story the way he thinks
it should be told
um so i got to kind of like have the
experience making the film and then do
the same thing and then a lot of the
voiceovers some of them were written but
anthony i sat while i was filming the
movie i would do journal entries every
day especially when i was
filming the prison stuff i would write
in my journal and all those little pages
that were on the walls all
i wrote all of those and i think we use
a lot of those journal entries that i
had personally written
in the voiceover and so i think it kind
of helped because it felt like
it came from me you know it came from my
heart came from my experience and how i
saw steve at the time um
so i just had to read them and i think i
ended became more choked up or
or being shocked by some of the emotions
i went through as well and organizing
that so um
it was very unique i've never done it
like that before and i don't know i
haven't done a voiceover since to be
honest so
he plays the exact way you just
described it now so job well done and if
you do it again maybe take that same
approach
before they kick me out of this room i
do want to bring up an upcoming project
because
big congratulations on the joseph alone
casting that
yes huge and extremely exciting for you
i know you have a musical background but
playing someone like that
feels like next level like the highest
possible tier kind of stuff
so what kind of lies ahead for you i
guess in terms of you know
training and prepping to nail that kind
of role
it isn't it is i'm so grateful i am so
excited the script is
stunning it's stunning and steven
williams our director is an incredible
human
and he's so smart and like the process
so far i don't start shooting into like
three months from now
but at the prep right now this is crazy
i
have to learn how to fence i have to
learn how to you know i'm i'm in violin
lessons right now it's supposed to be
practicing four hour day four hours a
day it's supposed to be
um it's just a lot a lot that comes with
it uh but
it is it is very exciting and just
learning about this man
and embodying this man right now has
been such a gift to me and i think
i think i'm sure everyone's gonna love
this movie be really
it's gonna be a great history lesson you
know i got all the faith in the world
you are gonna nail the role the movie's
gonna be great and now we have this one
to celebrate so thank you
so much for taking the time to talk
monster with us and for everyone out
there it's on netflix streaming now
check it out thank you so much calvin
it's always a pleasure talking to you
you too you too